let's talk about wig cutting real quick
so
i've i've seen weight cutting
break some of the toughest
fighters wrestlers grapplers ever like
burn out break like where they makes you
want to quit the sport yep um so you
know this is what people don't often
talk about but mentally is one of the
hardest things especially when you're
doing it kind of wrong
because it becomes a mental war
so you competed like you said your whole
career at 81 kilograms
you walked around at
88.89 so about 15 pounds
sometimes 20 pounds
over that give or give or take
and so what uh
what was your process like mentally and
physically first of all maybe you can
comment on when the weigh-ins are
relative to the matches
and then what was your process like
leading like a week ahead a day ahead
an hour ahead minutes ahead of the the
weigh-in
man everyone
varies tremendously because we're not
like
most sports because you're dropped off
in foreign countries with
who knows what right some places have
sauna some places have treadmills
i went to a place one time in china in
the middle of winter where the roads
were frozen with ice and we had to use
our hotel rooms because
it was you couldn't sweat outside
because it was too cold right um and
every one of my olympics the weight cut
was different just given my mass when i
went to
2008 i was probably like 80 to 83 kilos
walking around so weight cutting wasn't
a thing for me
in
london we actually weighed in the
morning of so weigh-ins were at like 6
a.m
and the olympics were always beneficial
to me because they actually don't start
until like 10 or 11.
so you actually were able to recover
where on the circuit you would weigh in
at 6 00 am and the competition started
at 8 am
it's like well i was cutting weight at
5am
and most of it for people who are not
familiar but maybe you can also correct
me
most of it you're really just getting
the water out of your system it was
water at that point yeah at that like 24
hours before even like so are you like
an hour before
but yeah but like leading up to it um
and do have you eaten the day before do
you try to minimize the amount of food
in your system my weight cutting process
was a little bit different than than
most people because
i like to eat
um
i'm not
i'm not the type of person that believes
your athletic career is determined by
your nutrition
right i don't i don't believe that i
think some sports are built that way but
when it comes to combat sports like
you know your ability to knock somebody
out has nothing to do with whether you
had a cheeseburger or a salad
my ability to throw you is not
determined by that i may be able to
perform better because i've eaten a
certain way
but not enough to justify an entire diet
change
your body is built and my body is built
to operate with certain things that i've
had in my system for years
yeah i think
i'm with you but i also believe that
there's a
mental aspect so if you're surrounded by
people that tell you diet matters
then if your diet is off you're going to
believe you're going to be off because
the people around you tell you your diet
should be good so yeah
i think it's like it's the same i i've
had an argument with matthew walker
who's uh
who's a sleep scientist about sleep and
it's like if you believe sleep is
essential it's essential to get eight
hours of sleep every single night
perfectly
then you're going to be very stressed
when you don't get it and then i think
it will negatively affect the stress
will negatively affect your longevity in
all kinds of aspects of your life if you
actually just learn to truly listen to
your body become a scientist for your
own body with sleep and food it might
end up that it will be the eight hours a
night or whatever but it might be
something else and probably die here i
remember when i was meeting with the
usoc nutritionist after
london it was probably around
[Music]
2014 i think
and
when we had our team meeting at the
beginning of the year and i was talking
to him he was talking about the
nutrition plans that he could put us on
and i was like time out i've done the
usoc thing like i've done the couscous
i've done the lemon in my water
i go
i'm full [ __ ] the kind of juice this is
oh boy like there was just because
there's like a cookie cutter plan right
right and i was like
look here's what i want you to do i go
i'll listen to you
but you're gonna walk into the 7-eleven
across the street from the usoc and if
you can't buy it in that 7-eleven
it's not on my plan right
i go because i go to places where
the only thing i can eat is pringles and
a snickers bar
i've done that like i've flown to
azerbaijan stayed in a hotel where the
restaurant is closed usa judo hasn't
paid for the meal plan
and the only thing that's available is
the thing across the street so you were
eating
pringles before fighting a grand slam
event while cutting 20 pounds and a
snickers bowl yeah
that's some like that's some rocky [ __ ]
okay build me a nutrition plan go for it
because i'm not paying my own way
to travel with
14 days of food
right
i mean that's that's one of the magic of
your whole career and also judo i mean
i'm sorry to say of course you want
athletes to be super rich
and super well funded from an athlete
perspective and the sport to be popular
and managed in an ultra-competent way
but that's not reality but as a fan it's
fun to watch somebody like you who's
exceptionally driven has to suffer in
all these different interesting ways
it's only suffering if you expect the
other side i don't expect it i accept it
for what it is which is why i write off
nutrition for athletes right because it
can be done without it as long as you
know to what you said before like
you don't believe you need it
some people believe they need it
so the mind getting your mind right is
the most important thing you know what i
believe i need what's that a snickers
bar when i'm tired
i want a little bit of sugar makes me
feel better
you want me to see you
yeah
i just love the the the visual of you
eating his thinking that's what that
became but that became part of my
nutrition plan
when the usoc guy wrote my nutrition
plan i was eating a burrito bowl
with brown rice white meat chicken black
beans guacamole cheese two chocolate
chip cookies and a diet coke this is
like chipotle uh it was below co but
same concept same same concept with two
because chocolate chip cookies because i
needed the sugar i was
i was
88 kilos when i stepped on the scale at
6.3 body fat now i got to make 81.
what really yeah
and the usoc was like hey
you know you can't you can't fight 81
anymore you have to fight 90s and i go
i'm already into the quad
i'm not changing i go
build me a plan where i can do this and
now we have to have an acceptable weight
cut like it's just what do you want me
to do
i'm not the ijf i can't just change the
fact that it takes two years to qualify
i know where i'm at i know what i have
to go through and i accept the
consequences it is what it is we want
all right so what was the process i mean
can you can you speak to so you you wake
up early in the morning the the day of
the weigh-ins a few hours before
technically my weight cut never started
until i got off a plane
and to a hotel
and how many hours three days
so it's a three day cut to three days
mentally you're thinking of it that way
yep and then you're still eating i eat
every day and then like what do you load
up on water maybe as you start and then
nope or did the water start just it is
what it is
[Laughter]
so you i mean it's a slow
you're not actually like
sweating all three days yeah
but then it's like torture to
sleep part of the process
are you able to sleep sometimes
it depends
so you're dehydrated further and further
dehydrated with six seven percent body
fat
trying to lose 10 pounds i even
developed a way to drink water out of a
bottle where i don't drink anything but
i feel like i have
uh swishing it what's the no so like i
take like a bottle of water and like if
we were to like to draw a line on it
i would tip it and i would go like this
and you would draw that line but like i
drink now water for 20 seconds or
whatever it is
and i feel like
i get the fix yeah brain told me i got
there
no problem
that's amazing man you just
your mind's a very powerful tool and
the the problem a lot of people have is
they don't accept the reality of the
situation
they [ __ ] about the reality of the
situation i just
first of all you could always quit
right yep so like you're not ex never
missed weight
never never miss
you can you can perform poorly you can't
miss wait don't miss way don't miss wait
because
you you can always win regardless of how
bad the weight cut is
you can never win if you miss weight
but your your brain is also really good
maybe not your brain
but i know my brain i think most
people's brains are good at generating
the more desperate things become the
better it's generating excuses
so what were you doing with your mind
that
resulted in you never
missing weight the plan
so
like i said like my weight cut would
never start until i got to the hotel
because
i didn't check my weight the morning of
i didn't check my weight when i got
there
i just while i'm traveling i'm doing
things at like a minimal level
but i'm never not giving myself
something i'm craving
if i'm thirsty i'm drinking a diet coke
if i'm hungry
i'm buying a snickers bar i'm buying a
sandwich
i am
and i accept the consequences when i get
there and then when i get there
if i step on the scale and it says 88
kilos i instantaneously know exactly
what it's going to take to be 81. and
then you just follow like a robot follow
a very specific process yep
and then i mean because there's a lot of
seconds in three days
seconds and minutes and you just i just
know exactly what it takes from my body
i know exactly what a one hour gym
workout wearing a sauna suit
is gonna take i know exactly what i'm
gonna lose on day one and i know exactly
what i'm gonna lose on day three because
they're not the same so i can instantly
look at a hotel
decide is there a bathroom sauna gym
temperature of the gym
access to the gym and when it is
access to the judo mats my training
partners
the roads versus street lights the
weather outside i can take a look at
that environment and say this is my
weight this is weigh-ins and
instantaneously in my head there's a
plan to make weight and you have a sense
of how much sweat adds up to
to 10 pounds how much sweat plus time
yeah just
and i make sure in my plan
all of my meals and how much water i
need in between
is allocated to still make weight
because you have to eat or drink during
that time
are you incorporating like mental
exhaustion into this that doesn't exist
it doesn't it doesn't
you